you guys have been asking me to make a
berkey training video for some time now
but i've been a little bit reluctant
bucky is like batman on steroids
he's ostensibly a normal human and yet
he can perform
absolutely insane feats kesuki itagaki
attempts to provide illogical
explanations for many of baki's
abilities
drawing on scientific explanations and
genuine martial arts techniques
but here's the thing those explanations
take some serious poetic license
are endorphins a thing sure but they
won't make you an invincible fighter
surely adrenaline and the
fight-or-flight response would have made
more sense to go with here
bucky likewise can perform pull-ups too
fast for anyone to see
eventually snapping the bar off and
flying up into the air
when he sprints he leaves craters behind
him his vertical jump is 20 foot
and that's another problem there's just
too much to delve into here where would
we even start with a bucky training
program
carrying your entire gym up a mountain
throwing yourself off a cliff
wrestling apes fighting imaginary
praying mantises
i didn't feel like a workout could
really do justice to bucky's training
even if we tried to focus on his
aesthetics that would mean developing
back musculature to the point of it
looking like a demon face
nothing in this manga is subtle but then
i decided to take a step back and look
at the themes here
obviously we can't develop a 20-foot
vert and i'm not gonna recommend
training to the point of hallucination
but we can apply some of the commonly
occurring principles to our own workouts
and take on the spirit of berkey
training and this actually gives me an
opportunity to talk about some awesome
stuff
and to demonstrate some of the things
i've spoken about recently in a more
practical setting
yes it's finally time for a berkey
training video
forget beast mode this is bucky mode
the pillars of bucky training so what
are those themes and principles
bucky's a grappler or effectively an mma
fighter he needs to train like a fighter
and especially in ways that relate to
grappling bucky pushes himself
ridiculously far to break through human
limitations
bucky workouts are badass i think any
backy workout that tells you to perform
regular curls and squats
is going to fall a little flat the good
news here is that many of these things
go hand in hand
so let's start with rotational strength
and fighting apes because why not
rotational strength is your ability to
exert force on the transverse plane to
twist your body against resistance this
is critical for fighters seeing as
rotational strength is what you use when
throwing a punch or a kick
and it's what you use when trying to
twist an opponent to the floor
bucky demonstrates his incredible power
as a fighter early on in the first saga
when he wrestles the yasha krag ape this
is of course a little beyond the realms
of believability
just a tad but there is one real world
comparison we can draw
wrestlers that used to fight bears the
bears wore muzzles and they had the
nails clipped
it's also extremely cruel and definitely
not cool
but this still demonstrates just how
much force a much small
human is capable of generating an ape
would rip your arms off though
locked in a hold with a barrel ape your
only hope would be to pull against and
twist them to the ground
and as i've discussed in the past if all
you're doing is squats and deadlifts you
won't have developed that amount of
torque
there are those that proclaim that all
you need is the big three lifts but this
simply doesn't make sense
twisting the body requires strength in
the obliques the serratus and more
you can't create muscle damage or
metabolic stress or mechanical tension
in the muscles that aren't directly
involved in a movement
no matter how much you want that to be
true if strength applies globally then
you would only need one exercise
this also ties into my recent
discussions regarding the importance of
training standing up
the bench press is performed lying down
therefore you aren't bracing the spine
and the core when you push
and you aren't coordinating that
strength with feedback from your muscle
spindles
as olympic wrestling coach dustin myers
explains
when you're on your back pressing up
it's too late you're pinned
i think it's important to de-emphasize
everyone's favorite exercise
the bench press and incorporate some
different types of presses
that also require a lot of core and back
stability
this pains me as much as anyone i love
the bench press
in other words if you have amazingly
powerful pecs but never use them in an
upright stance
you're more likely to push yourself over
and again simply performing regular
exercises
that everyone else uses well that ain't
backy training the same goes for pulling
strength which is even more important
for a grappler
this is where band and cable training
comes in alongside sandbags
kettlebells madison balls and club bells
these challenge you in every plane
forcing to fight against momentum
and shifting centers of gravity and they
challenge your strength endurance
they also offer us the repetition
without repetition that i discussed in
the last video
a quote from legendary movement
physiologist nikolai bernstein
man it's almost like i planned these
things out or something in other words
it's no good only ever performing the
same movement with perfect technique on
a nice flat surface
because that's not how you use your
strength in the real world this is also
the benefit of training outside
training barefoot and more there's a
reason that mma fighters gravitate
towards functional training methods
and not simple powerlifting programs
i should note here that bucky training
in the manga does include the bench
press
but his bench at age 17 is rated to over
320 pounds when the manga starts
at which point he's already a champion
this is impressive
sure but it's not impossible it's about
the only feat in this manga that isn't
completely bonkers
but the inclusion of the bench press is
also good because the bench press allows
us to pack on weight and it allows us to
somewhat isolate the pecs
triceps and shoulders this in turn means
we can trigger more adaptation
the key is to practice this and upright
dynamic movements in combination
otherwise you're going to be really
powerful at pushing yourself away from
the opponent
as you'll lack the core stability
necessary to stay in one place
a baki training program should place
moves like the bench press and deadlift
at the start of the workout
after warming up and then follow these
up with more complex movements
that use a lighter weight and
incorporate endurance alternatively we
can place these on a separate day
which may make more sense as most of us
won't want to carry our power racks into
the woods
what's significantly more impressive
than the bench itself is that baki
carries all that weight and his bench
equipment up the mountain
that's about a thousand times more
difficult and impossible clearly bucky
favors functional strength
the kind of strength and endurance that
comes from a farmer's walk uphill
and this is where we see the other two
aspects of bucky training come into play
pushing ourselves ridiculously far and
training in a way that's truly badass
the strength training and work capacity
are also critical here a fighter needs
to be able to continue exerting dynamic
strength for a long time
again functional tools are perfect for
this recently user curtis cameron
shared a video of the patreon exclusive
bioneers facebook group
that detailed the history of 19th
century indian club swinging contests
you can watch the video over at physical
culture historians it's fantastic and
fascinating video
and i'll link to it in the description
down below in it we hear about club
swinging strongmen like thomas bax
they were able to swing indian clubs
continuously for days on end without
sleep
if that's not the backy levels of insane
i don't know what is and this also
demonstrates the crucial aspect of the
iron will
of mental hardiness and pushing yourself
past that point where you want to stop
ex-navy seal and ultramouth and runner
david goggins talks about the 40
rule how at the point where your body is
telling you that you can't train any
further
you've probably only used about 40 of
your max capacity
and this does trigger endorphins
certainly when performing endurance
tasks as this is what gives us the
runners high i'm going to go into this
in detail later but suffice to say that
we get feedback from our body
regarding fatigue and exhaustion at
least partially from the free nerve
endings in the fascia
enteroceptors however this raw data
needs to then be
interpreted by contextual cues and cues
from the environment
in order to result in an action or
feeling in short if you can convince
yourself that those fatigue signals are
a good thing
then you can overcome the desire to stop
and power through but it's crucial to
understand the difference between your
body making excuses
for you and actual pain that signals an
incoming injury
as much as bucky is cool we do need to
be smart about our training here
but exercises like heavy carries and the
car push are perfect demonstrations of
moves that build endurance into their
very dna
this is something that jc santana talks
about recalibrating
the human will of his fighters he
explains in one talk how the car push is
the perfect tool for this
of course any backy workout also needs
to include
high repetitions of calisthenics
movements things like push-ups
and hindu squats and when we're talking
hindi squats we're once again
talking about the great wrestler gamma
who apparently used to do something like
1 000 or
even 5 000 hindi squats a day these are
squats performed
on the balls of your feet and they're
fantastic for building up massive
quads which we can all agree that bucky
definitely
has now we're out in the woods swinging
heavy clubs heaving heavy rocks
carrying logs and more maybe we're
pushing cars too
we're training like real life anime
characters and it's no surprise that
david goggins
also has a propensity for carrying logs
around this is the closest thing to
bucky training i could conjure up
but it's not new if you want a cool
example of someone who trains like this
then check out
spec ops pat mcnamara who trains like an
absolute beast
and if you want to learn more about mace
kettlebell and club training then
definitely go check out mark wilden's
channel
which is just the best resource for that
kind of thing and while we can't go
wrestling bears or apes maybe we could
try
wrestling trees trees are the perfect
isometric training tool and again
we're drawing on great examples of
historical strongmen here
like the wrestler gamma who also trained
with clubs and maces and spent time
trying to heave trees out of the ground
gamma reportedly won over 5 000
fights with no losses emma also
reportedly performed a thousand gamma
casts
which were presumably just called casts
at that point with an 80 pound club
every single day
again bucky levels what's important
during all this though is to ensure that
our backy training is still built on a
foundation
of progressive overload the problem with
swinging things and lifting logs is that
it can be tough to track progress
again that's where it's still useful to
include exercises like the bench press
and also more dynamic movements that are
easier to track and improve upon
like the cable wood chop for instance or
calisthenic skills performed for high
repetitions
so that's what a backy workout would
look like if you want to see a full
routine
then be sure to check out the link in
the description below and this will take
you to my blog where i've detailed an
example
it's completely free to read online of
course it's more about the concepts than
the specific execution though
and while you're there be sure to take a
look around i upload a lot more content
to the blog that doesn't get made into
video formats
i've recently discussed hill sprints in
detail talked about how we'll all be
working in the gig economy soon
and discuss whether studies or
experience are more useful for guiding
training
decisions if you want more bioneer
content that is where to find it
of course if you want a more in-depth
total program for functional strength
endurance and cognitive performance then
be sure to check out my ebook and
training program
super functional training and there's a
discount on right now whilst many of us
are still in lockdown here in the uk
we've just gone into a second full
lockdown so
my hair's bad again so if you found this
video useful and interesting guys if you
did then please leave a like and share
around that helps me out
immensely thank you so much for watching
this one and stay tuned for much more
like it
and yeah bye for now
oh and guys if you caught my last video
then you'll know that i also have a new
print book available for pre-order
that's called functional training and
beyond which is available from january
19th and which will serve as a detailed
introduction to using functional
training concepts
to enhance physical and mental
performance it's a journey through the
history of physical culture
that addresses the merit of countless
training styles hopefully it's an
eye-opening read
that will provide everyone from
beginners to pros with some new ideas to
incorporate into their workouts
check out the link in the description
below for more and thanks again for all
your support